we all crave our grandmother's cooking
right well what if there were a place
that you could go anytime and get that
home-cooked meal from anywhere in the
world
Mangia Mangia Mangia Mangia that place
exists he said Milan
just behind that scaffolding right over
there meet Joe he's Italian by way of
Brooklyn my name is Jodi Caravela and I
own Enoteca Maria we don't employ a chef
we employ grandmothers would you look in
the restaurant in 2006 he noticed
something every culture was coming to
the restaurant to celebrate these
Italian grandmother's so I saw it to
myself
unlike for the beef we celebrated to
everybody's culture and so knowledge of
the world was born there are probably
somewhere between 30 and 40
grandmother's from different countries
my name is Heba I saw my Dania my name
is Lou Golson and from Moscow Russia
cataleya vengo de lima 13 - sri lanka no
Gary Kaplan Ireland from our menu we're
sorry this Argentine each night there
are two grandmother's cooking one is
always Italian the other from somewhere
else when they're in the kitchen cooking
it's a completely different energy it's
their day to shine it's their day to
show what their cultural cuisine is all
about you know it sounds kind of corny
but they do cook with love and this
feeling for Joe's about more than the
restaurant when I opened the Enoteca
I was really grief-stricken
my mom and my sister had had it was
comforting to have the grandmothers in
the kitchen cooking and you know they
would pinch my cheek and say you want to
try this and at that point I realized
that what we were doing was much bigger
than I thought it was going to be when
you walk through the restaurant if you
listen every table that you pass by
they're talking about their mothers or
they're talking about their grandmothers
it kind of evokes a trip down memory
lane
[Music]